i get dm sometimes like  you think you're walt disney and i reply  and say things like no i'm trying to be  that i'm gonna enjoy the process of  trying good for you you didn't go into  this with any intent other than let's  just have fun be friends for me the  reason patient panda and empathy  elephant are so buzz lightyear and woody  for me is like i believe if i can teach  people i've tried to do it through  garyvee but i'm a very narrow vessel  with me friends i can change the world  through those characters gary i know  like i love you nothing makes me happier  i can't wait for my garyvee backpack  [ __ ] swag i'll be in your first animated  movie oh your little kids are gonna be  super famous cause i'm gonna only wear v  friends clothes from second to ninth  grade  okay they're in